maybe you can help me with this with
LGBTQ if genders non-binary what do we
do with the B the B yeah bisexual
alright very special episode here today
I know I know I was just off there she
when I can see him I can't hear them
because since this is our first meeting
mm-hmm and I know we've disagreed on
issues in the past and I think we agree
on some issues now I think let's go
right into it you can follow her on
Twitter at Go Green 18
of course you probably know her YouTube
channel Laci green TV MS green thank you
for being here
hi Steven how you do it I'm doing well
how are you I'm very good yeah this
doesn't need to be awkward or weird I
know you've met a ton of more right
leading people now and I think I just
heard you speaking with mr. Reagan over
there who's a little bit in the center
yeah my boyfriend I wouldn't describe
him as Center but okay you know whatever
funny chick but I'm glad we finally have
you on the show thank you for coming on
I appreciate it
it was one that was really requested by
a lot of fit by the way not to be
confused for those looking at the plugs
as glozell green no noted Oh Lord now
Laci green oh well no no we don't want
to short you little obvious you never
know if they search it you know noted
feminists and actually has one finally
degree in a bathtub full of fruit leaf
role of fruit loops probably not you
never know you never know
there's a bright YouTube future ahead
where I'm bathing in cereal you can just
make it a patreon bonus if someone pays
enough they can watch you bathe in Froot
Loops and apply chaps and there would be
someone who would do that I guarantee
you let me ask this it was really
requested by a lot of fans
you were a noted feminist I think we did
even some rebuttals a long time ago
don't hold it against us with some of
your videos that were very popular and
then you you mentioned you know taking
the red pill and obviously this has been
documented a lot of people are familiar
with it but for people who aren't can
you kind of set it up and explain to
them what does that mean for for Laci
green what was that
like well I was that video was mostly
just me saying that I was willing to
talk to people who consider themselves
red pillars I would not call myself a
red pillar right any way but yeah I have
always really you know I come from a
really conservative background I have
family members that voted for Trump and
they're very religious and they live at
the middle of nowhere you know I am NOT
like insulated liberal in any sense the
word and they started talking about some
of these things on my youtube channel
and how important it is to just sort of
like sit down have a beer have a chat
with people who see things differently
than you and to really understand where
other people are coming from and I think
everyone should do that and we should
all be open to changing our minds about
the things that we believe in learning
more and growing so I made this video
you know just not really thinking much
of it that I was going to oh that's a
mistake on the youtubes yeah yeah well I
there were lessons learned yes
especially namely don't read the comment
section but I appreciate that the
hutzpah that it took to do that anyway
yeah yeah so yeah I mean I I got a lot
of flack for that and continue to but
whatever you know I'm not why though I
don't understand why I mean what you
just said right now what you just
expressed seems entirely reasonable
that's something that we believe on this
program we have an open invitation to
anyone and we'll allow them a platform
to speak I understand why you leave
polarizing right how how is that pot
what kind of Fleck do you get for that I
think people from across the spectrum
who just have really hyper partisan
opinions feel that you know what
regardless of where they're coming from
on the political spectrum feel about
talking being willing being willing to
listen to someone else and try to hear
them out and understand them is sort of
like conceding how you see things or
like agreeing with them and maybe I just
communicated it poorly or maybe people
are just so polarized and tribalistic
online that it just sort of created this
spiraling frenzy
but it's stupid I mean it's really
idiotic you know yes it obviously is you
see across the spectrum so I know you
mentioned you've talked about how people
on the Left feminists sort of thought
you were a turncoat and you had had
death threats against you I heard about
your story in a parking lot because you
would accidentally used the word [ __ ]
when quoting quit Chris Crocker who used
it himself and they said you led to the
deaths I don't this is this people watch
your videos I'm not I'm not hurling mud
lacey has talked about if it sounds
absurd it sounds absurd to me as well
but what kind of flack would you get you
know across the spectrum on on the right
for saying hey let's have a conversation
how are they mad about that a lot of
people saw me as trying to like just do
it for abused or accusing me of trying
to trick them or you know not being
willing to have the conversation
themselves because they felt that I had
hurt them in some crazy way you know
like you've done so much damage there's
no way you know anybody on our side
shouldn't talk to you and it's just
people are just crazy across the board
like everyone just needs to chill out
you know just have a conversations you
know I think the part of it though was
maybe like I didn't see the videos you
made to me but like some people made
some videos that I would say we're
pretty inflammatory and close-minded
themselves ours probably were you
needn't watch them but that's the
majority yes okay cool well noted you
know I think that that sort of attracts
the type of person who isn't really open
to having conversations or learning more
they just want to hear things that
reinforce their own worldview yeah no
III agree with you and we talk a lot
about you know I've worked at Fox News
for four and a half years before I
founded that no yeah it was not a fun
experience no not very cool as a matter
I think it's the opposite of cool when
at commercial break and I'm on a panel
there selling self lubricating pocket
catheters I don't think of it I can't
think anything less cool than that Lacey
but I walk in bathtubs appreciate so you
know I will say though having been you
know I was raised in a socialist
province in Connecticut there is no
conservative there's liberal and liberal
separatists so like you I was not raised
in a in a far-right insular bubble there
no right-wing it didn't exist I came to
the United States to learn about it that
being said I've definitely in my
experience having been in Quebec and
been here and with with speech laws in
place like Canada which much more
closely mimic Europe I've really seen
the right here to be more open to it to
a dialog this is a matter of fact you're
kind of a rarity for people on the left
many of them won't come on the show many
of them don't have conversations at all
yeah yeah yeah that is an interesting
thing I thought so I don't know like I
can't I don't like making
generalizations but I feel like maybe
this is something that is being
exacerbated online because most of
people that I'm friends with like in the
in the real world are down to have a
conversation but one thing that I've
noticed happens online a lot in on the
left is people have this idea kind of
like what I was how you about before
right where if you talk to somebody who
has views that you believe are abhorrent
or hurtful or harmful or whatever but
that is giving them power it's giving
them a platform this is what all of the
feminists youtubers sort of disowned me
over right they said that I was like
empowering yeah right or whatever like
empowering the people that I disagree
with by by simply talking to them right
and and not only is that their that idea
but anybody even you know like myself or
anybody who doesn't really see it that
way they're fans will come after them
right so there's like this huge risk
that you take and nobody wants to you
know piss off their fans so yeah I
understand we've I've seen a small
portion of that for example we've talked
don't agree with Alex Jones on much of
anything but I've done a show several
times his son's a fan and his son you
know given him merchandise and I've been
on his show and told me I disagree them
some conservatives I said well you're
you're enabling some of this
conspiratorial views and pretty clear I
mean I've been on MSNBC and BBC and Sky
News that being said it was a very very
small percentage of people it seems in
comparison to the reaction to you from
feminists where what you're saying what
you're saying isn't that inflammatory
that's the thing yeah I don't I don't
think so but some people do and they
still give me you know so post about me
every day which is like
what do you do it ya know I mean to me
it's like if you have if there are real
problems in the world and real problems
in your life why are you obsessing over
what people on it like random ask people
on the internet do but doesn't really
have like much write effect on the world
yes and I do think a lot of people there
focus on that that's why when we do this
show we've we've always tried to focus
on for example if I disagree I don't
want to strum and we use clips and
quotes in policy from Bernie and Hillary
and Young Turks and we say here the
mainstream views that we disagree with
because anyone can find the Westboro
Baptist Church and your act as though
there are more than 14 members with
flippers you know or a bread yeah and
the same thing on the left but you know
there's some mainstream views for me as
a conservative on the red on the left
that I find disconcerting let me and he
said you wouldn't consider yourself a
red pillar I understand that it sounds
to me like the main thing that's changed
is your view on having a conversation
maybe maybe freedom of speech open
dialogue a little more is that kind of
really when you say was red pill that's
the fundamental difference between pre
2017 Laci green and post yeah I think
that's the main thing but also I I
sympathize and understand some of the
criticisms of the feminist movement that
are made online and I agree with a lot
of them so maybe that's if you want to
call that red bell you know I I think we
don't need anymore our thoughts I think
people get the picture if someone's
already condemned you for being on the
show I understand it's like it's like
consumers like not a Nazi not a Nazi
heard the audio only version yeah that's
probably enough not a Nazi but I think I
think school vouchers might be good he's
a Nazi I knew it so then let me ask you
this you say sympathize what would be
different
what views would you say have changed in
in pre 2017 Laci green in post so you
say sympathizes let's start with that
you know I have always thought this
stuff and I've talked about it on line
many times because I myself have been
victim of really vitriolic mob attacks
online yeah many times so you know I've
always growing up on the internet and
being someone who just kind of like
shares their opinions online have seen
the dark underbelly of the the movements
that I am aligned with and I feel like
I've seen all the dark
your belly a spear I'm in and that so
much and that's your job and it's pretty
horrible but yeah I I would say the main
thing is just feeling like there are
some aspects of the feminist movement
that are just really toxic that had been
really toxic to me that have been really
toxic to people that I know and you know
I have always felt that way it sort of
talked about it it was kind of scared to
poke the Beast but now I really don't
give up because I really think that
there has been a tipping point where it
has become so toxic that it's actually
hurting the very causes that I believe
in okay what elements I guess when you
say Tom when you say toxic of feminism
specific um yeah well there's a lot of
things but I think one of them for
instance is like the Mott but the hate
mobs when somebody says or does
something problematic you know that that
is do you not like there's the eye out
for those listening audio she's doing it
again she's doing again people listen to
audio sometimes and they go what why did
you I'm like no no you missed it so okay
just but I appreciate it I just say but
you know I because I hate that word
problematic like what is that
I don't even that's a change because he
used to use that word I always use that
word in sort of ironic sense and if you
like go back and watch my MTV videos
people didn't really pick up that I was
kind of making fun of it they thought I
was serious because you know I guess
that's a legitimate mistake turn based
sort of a feminist Tony Clifton you
played them and that's that's okay I
respect that
yeah I also just think people get so
like hyped up about words like triggered
or problematic it's like everyone just
you know it's like a buzz word that
people lose their minds that but yeah
but this coming back to what I was
saying sure use this idea that like if
you do or say something that is steam
problematic you are now a horrible
person who deserves to die and lose your
job and you you caused all this terrible
stuff you know you're you're responsible
for the violence against all these
people just for like maybe having kind
of an ignorant or different even opinion
not something and I think that's a
really toxic mentality that makes it so
that people can actually have a
conversation about things and they can't
actually hear each other
or respect each other because nobody is
going to be this
like image of ideological purity there's
all these purity tests right and as soon
as you've been deemed not pure enough
for the left you're just done they'll
throw you in the trash and one one thing
that I like in a line with some of my
more moderate to right weighting friends
is this idea that we're still human
beings and we should still be able to
like see through our differences and
work through them in a respectful way
you know and I I really value loyalty
I'm a very employable person and I find
more of my like politically I find more
of my moderate to right-leaning friends
are at the end of the day even if they
think I'm like a crazy nutjob liberal or
whatever right they aren't gonna just a
bit up and leave me and you know stop
talking to me like many of my liberal
friends have you know I've never been
abandoned by my right-wing friends over
my views left-wing absolutely that isn't
that is interesting you know I uh I
guess never really thought of it but
having had left-wing friends like Sally
Cohen in the show and when people kind
of doggie piled on her I'd try to say
listen I disagree with her but she's a
very decent human being that being no
you know what you're absolutely right
now that I go back all my left-wing
friends from Montreal none of them like
me anymore
they all hate me then again they might
have just been looking for an excuse so
um many do how would we say so
something's you talked about quite a bit
since I have you here and you talk about
sort of respectfully either finding
common ground or disagreement like toxic
masculinity you talked about quite a bit
and it seems as though you've
transitioned a little but certainly in
your explanation of how it's often
perceived or described how would you
describe your view then and now if it's
if it's changed I don't think it's
really ever changed I have always felt
that there are elements of how we raise
girls and how we raise boys those gender
roles that we you know uphold so highly
in our culture that there are some roles
for boys and girls that are hurtful to
them and could be toxic to others and
when we're talking about toxic
masculinity that pigpen take in
particular and one of the big issues is
telling boys to suppress their feelings
and
deal with their upset and their emotions
with violence you know I think that men
should be able to express their feelings
and when we shame them and call them
boys and being a little girl or whatever
for having feelings that that is a
really tough thing to do to a human
being yeah
because men are humans too and they're
gonna have feelings sometimes you know
sure yeah I don't I I don't think anyone
would disagree with that though I think
what I would disagree with is the
presupposition that society tells young
men to deal with their emotions through
violence you know that's where I would
say you know biologically young boys
tend to be more aggressive young boys
tend to be more hands-on more
rambunctious
and a lot of them are frustrated because
we put them in a public education system
which is designed for women not young
boys and we tell them not to be not only
not to be violent but sometimes not to
be young boys which is a bit rough and
tumble yeah I think I think you know I I
will agree with you that boys because of
testosterone and you know that's a
generalization but in general they do
have a lot of aggressive energy or a lot
of energy in general and that's why I
think that we need to have positive
outlets for boys like you know I think
sports is a great great outlet for
people's energy and girls have that
energy to sometimes you know it really
just depends but sports and healthy
competitions ways to get that energy out
in healthy ways that doesn't hurt people
I don't think there's ever this message
that like well sometimes there is but
usually it's not like you should go out
beat someone up but sometimes it is
sometimes it's like oh you're having a
problem with someone at school you
should like show them who's boss
you know you should take them down and
not put up with their crap because
that's how you show that you have
self-respect as a man and I think that
that is like not a very productive thing
to tell boys my dad told my little
brother this all the time like you
should just you know beat him up and I'm
like maybe not though yeah maybe we can
say yeah I've never ever heard that in
my I wonder how much with with I guess
sort of modern third wave feminism is
this perceived societal conditioning
versus what's happening in actuality
because if you look at any public school
any public program any intramural sports
they punish severely any outbursts
of violence and I've never heard anyone
personally tell a young boy to be
violent I've heard them say defend
yourself my dad told me that I almost
think that telling young boys they
shouldn't be the way that they are with
checks and balances is more toxic than
trying to create outlets that maybe
aren't the most conducive toward
actually like you said sort of expending
some of this this aggressive
testosterone Laden energy well I don't
think that anybody I mean I think for
one thing intramural sports is different
than how boys and girls are socialized
like there's no doubt about it that we
do tell sure and there's there's a lot
of data to back this up that we do feel
more comfortable with boys be expressing
their emotions physically and solving
problems physically and you see this in
the movies everywhere like you know you
see this at bars and at schools and you
know there's just sort of this idea that
if you're a guy who has self-respect you
know you should stand up for yourself
and the way you stand up for yourself
may include physical violence sometimes
and I think that this this message can
also come out in relationships because
you know we have a real abuse problem in
a lot of teen relationships you know I
don't know what the statistic is but any
any amount is too much right of abuse
and it's not just physical abuse like
men and women abused each other in
different ways
men are more likely to be physically
violent and women are more likely to be
emotionally psychologically abusive yeah
so we maybe part of that is like our
biological nature as males and females
but I do think the message is reinforced
socially I guess this room could where
do you think it's reinforced socially
for men to be physically abusive to
women well no not that's not what I said
well he said in a relationship so you
said these some of these ideas are
reinforced socially and men are more
physically abusive and yeah I mean what
I mean is like the this idea that men
it's acceptable for men to handle their
problems with violence and physicality
is something that we see not only in
solving interpersonal problems between
other men but in the
relationships as well we don't really
teach people how to deal with their
emotions and how to have healthy
communication so that they could deal
with these aspects of being human in a
healthy way yeah I respectfully I would
disagree there I think young boys are
physical in nature and I think that's
separate right because this is biology
versus a behavior and acting out
violently toward another person I think
one is innate and I think one is
something that's not so so she like you
think it's innate to like be people up
at school I think young men are more see
I think young men are much more physical
I think young boys have much more as you
said physical energy and I think we sit
them for example in a classroom for
eight hours a day where young women tend
to thrive listening verbally
communicative and young men get
frustrated I don't think there's
anything wrong with teaching men how to
I'm here all the time now exercising how
to physically express themselves how to
have proper outlets I think it's a good
thing but then I also don't think that
socially I don't think we encourage men
to be violent in toxic life I think
that's you know I disagree I think
that's everywhere in the media so and
there's a lot of data to back that up
you know there are a lot of socialized
messages about violence so that men
should be violent not that they should
be violent but that it is an acceptable
way to handle your feelings okay
well right now we're in we're handling
any disagreements to words and found a
lot of common ground let's go yeah you
know what I go physical because then the
biology comes into play which brings
kind of it so what other aspects I guess
of toxic masculinity and again I think
the reason this is important that I
understand that you sympathize with it I
think you see this point of view is that
young men who've been vilified for what
they are right for being men and then it
being referred to as toxic masculinity
then you know then you end up with a
rebound effect and you end up with you
know thus exodus ii adolescents we're
seeing these results right now with
young men who are afraid of
relationships what other aspects do you
think that maybe we could improve with
with men and women as far as how we
socialize them well I think that men are
also you know the way that we talk about
relationships is often in a very
entitled way and you see this across the
board with this idea
you know if if you're good to someone or
if you're nice to someone then they
should like you and they should want to
have sex with you and I see this not
just amongst men by the way I see this
and a lot of different it comes out in a
lot of different ways in different
communities this entitlement to sex
entitlement to relationships or feeling
like you know if nobody likes you that
is their problem when really maybe you
just be a likeable person yeah yeah
hence why I lost all my friends in
Montreal but they're also socialist so I
don't really care
no III agree with you on that I think
particularly this sort of alpha male
fake pickup culture I think it's a real
drama and I wrote about as a
traditionalist you know a Christian
conservative sort of complementarian
about waiting until I was married and I
was raked through the mud by none other
than Amy Schumer no less talk about how
that was a terrible sort of antiquated
view and for wanting to wait and
expressing that thought there were a lot
of benefits to and then that many people
would actually probably do well to
consider the same option and a big part
of that is obviously a big part of
women's lib in the feminist movement
sexual liberation so do you think that
maybe it's it's gone too far that way
because I think that exists quite a bit
on the feminist side as well
the hyper-sexualization that you're
you're kind of a failure if you don't
act in a predatory way sexually like men
right like this idea that if you're not
getting laid there's something wrong
with you because sex is so freely
available now so what's the issue right
well that women and men handle sex
differently you know I read a lot it
like if you realize these women's
magazines it's far worse than playboy or
penthouse letters at this point you read
cosmopolitan it's acting like women are
men and out there being sexual predators
and the way men are hard-wired and and
that seems to me like something that's
like you said it it's it's it's a purity
test is do you have like an example of
sure how to pick how to pick up how to
pick up guys at the bar how to you know
ten different ways to please a man and
every see every single cover is
basically
women are walking sex pots who are as
interested in spreading their seed and
the way men are biologically hardwired
to do doesn't mean it's right I think
men need to curb their biological urges
but as soon as a feminism runs counter
to the essence of men and women well I
don't think there's like a I don't like
essentializing men or women you know and
like I don't think we should boil people
these huge groups of people down to some
essential nature I think that's a little
bit very reductive
but yeah I think that there is it is
reductive in the sense that men and I
think this is it
I just want to answer that it is
reductive men and women are different
men are more sexually predatory women
are not by their nature I'm ok with that
reduction now that being said I don't
see people as nothing but black lives
matter nothing but LGBTQ after that
you're a male you're a female there's a
certain biological constraint there be
what you want to be but I'm okay with
being reductive and singing men and
women are different in that sense well
men and women are different partially
because of our biology you know males
and females and partially because of
power or socialized sport oh yeah I
think there are differences between men
and women absolutely
I just think the differences are
sometimes overstated they're they're
more hyped up we are very hyper focused
on how we're different when actually
there are a lot of things about us that
are the same for instance women like to
get laid - women love having sex so you
know most women I can't speak for all
women because that would be tyranny but
most women most women have most would
like to get laid in the in the
conference not all women in the
concentrates have an emotional
connection or relationship whereas a guy
can have sex with five people and rub
many guys not all guys that's why I see
the pickup culture in the male side and
not in the female side they don't have
the same emotional emotional hardwiring
sexually that women do as a general rule
I don't know how I feel about that
statement I think that's reductive but
in general in general I think it's true
that by some common combination of
biology and how we're socialized
that ends up being how the majority of
people who are men and women experience
it
but you know I don't think that there's
any sort of like innate sort of like
part of being a male that makes you this
creepy douchey pickup artist type you
know like that's that's a combination of
maybe sub 5 plus being a yes you know
and men are not men are not so this idea
that well all men are just really creepy
predatory guys just waiting to come out
I'd strongly disagree with that I didn't
say that though but I do say that men
men can be married in the long time go
there goes another one men are
hard-wired to spread their seed and they
want they want to be as promiscuous as
possible if left to their own devices
without a moral constraint women aren't
designed the same way women biologically
don't necessarily that's why the the
stereotype is the CAD to use the old
terms and then they nag the cat and the
nag the woman refuses sex or uses a
manipulation to let you said a
manipulation more emotional abuse
whereas the men are more physical does
that apply sexually as well and I think
that's important to recognize because if
we're going to teach and fix some of
these problems and find what makes us
the same teaching young men how to be
upstanding men husbands fathers is is
the most important thing of all and same
thing with women yeah well like I said I
disagree with your diagnosis of all men
and all women as these super reductive
categories but yes I do you think that
we should teach men and women how to
function successfully and healthfully in
their relationships so they can have
fulfilling lives yeah well I think I
think an example is Amy Schumer to go
back the reason that that's shocking is
because it's rare right the reason I
like the idea of a woman want you to
sleep around yes or what yeah I think
it's probably more weird for a number of
different reasons may be partially
biological partially it's been socially
unacceptable for women to be sexual
although that's changing and maybe
that's why you're seeing more of this
stuff that you described as male
behavior but they just kind of smell
behaved even though I separated behavior
versus biological urges I think there's
a really strong there needs to be an
importance on curbing biological urges
we are not just determined by our urges
or by our desires or by our carnal
to others yes exactly right or to
ourselves yeah this should probably be
curbed and we can and do curb them but
that's what I'm saying with like the
toxicity stuff is sort of the ways that
we make excuses for people to not curb
those impulses or to not curb those
learned behaviors yeah
yeah no I I agree and I think what we're
kind of disagreeing and missing each
other here's I think a lot of young men
have been told to curb it in the way
that's unnatural and unhealthy like you
would say you know hiding emotions
that's a very new thing I've talked
about this should go back to Lincoln
Roosevelt this idea that you are a jock
or you are an artist or you are an
intellectual that's a very new idea you
were the term I've talked about this was
actually jack-of-all-trades master of
one and the mocking of it became the
colloquialism master of none the truth
is you weren't considered a well-rounded
man unless you were all of these things
and it was perfectly fine to cry to hug
another man to kiss another man so I
think that's where people definitely
have gone astray but I also think that
in addition to that I think feminism has
really put a lot of burdens on young men
and that's why you see rejection of it
to really stop being young men we have
an education system it's base for young
women if you look at the way right now
Hollywood is reacting to things that we
would agree you know the me2 movement
the reaction is one that assumes that of
guilt right and so a lot of young men
feel browbeaten for being men is is my
point and the biology is an important
component that needs to be acknowledged
and rather than say hey you shouldn't be
so rambunctious let's sit you in a
classroom we should say all right young
men are rambunctious how do we channel
that positively well I think that young
men need to learn how to function in the
world and to be disciplined and you know
you need to learn to have respect for
yourself and the environment around you
and I think that's thing men should
learn as well yeah absolutely
and same thing with women and like you
said across the board there can be toxic
masculinity femininity it goes both ways
so let me ask ya this how this ties in
to because I know you've you've also
taken flack like you said from the
transgender community I think needlessly
for delineating between biology
and gender have your views on that
change at all since the quotes again for
people who aren't who are listening
audio read pilling are they
fundamentally the same I I guess I
should ask you what you would say the
same is like what's your well I know
that you've talked about how Jenna sex
is biological and that yeah gender is a
social construct how you presented it a
long time ago but I also know that you I
think rightfully talked about how
there's a lot of pseudoscience on LGBTQ
AIP blogs I've talked about a male brain
and a female brain transgenderism I this
is one thing that maybe you can help me
with this with LGBTQ hey I think that's
LGBTQ some people had a IP if genders
non-binary what do we do with the B the
B yeah bisexual I'm not sure I
understand your question what you mean
like bisexual means there's to prorate
right that's problematic okay I think I
see what you're saying bisexual well at
least the research refers to sex right
so male and female
whereas gender would be a different like
the non-binary designation refers more
to how people interpret their sex in the
world not necessarily about genitals you
know more about how you the masculine or
feminine or androgynous energies but
then the acronym makes no sense because
you have you have one that's biology
bisexual and then transgender which is
gender societal they've got to change
the whole acronym well some people have
made the criticism that sexuality or a
sexual orientation and gender identity
are two very different issues and so
they shouldn't be on the same acronym I
disagree with that because I think they
all kind of fall under they all have a
lot of shared shared traits and shared
struggles that all fall under the
anybody who doesn't have a
normative you know means it's a
conventional what we consider it made
Street sexuality er or gender identity
you know so those things have have
shared characteristics okay so yeah
they're different they are different
yeah well bisexual would be sexual so
it's basically someone's attracted to a
male or female biologically versus
gender so bisexual could be attracted to
a male biologically who identifies as
your guess is as good as mine at this
point and that's one thing I think that
you know people on the right have had
and since you talk so much on sexuality
and gender you know how many genders are
there how many pronouns are there what
do we what do we do so since it's a
societal issue what do we do societally
to deal with us how many can be put in a
driver's license what do you do with
voter registration it's an ever-changing
rulebook yeah I don't know what do you
think I I think I think with you yes
only to you yes I do well I think there
are practicalities to that view however
I also think that there you know a lot
of people just experience themselves in
the world differently and they want
language to describe their experience
and their identity and you know I think
that's a positive thing it doesn't hurt
me it doesn't hurt anyone else
I think the question of like driver's
licenses and stuff or what kinds of laws
should govern you know sex specific
spaces things like that
yeah there's complicated issues that
will have to mesh out and figure out how
to make it work but just in terms of how
people what pronouns they want to use or
how they want to describe themselves I
don't give it live your life yeah I
don't know I don't I don't think anyone
here does either but that's why Jordan
something like Jordan Peterson is so
proc popular because we're well past
that and now at the point of compelled
language you know in Canada was Bill
there and we have in New York where
landlords can't use the wrong pronouns
for fear being suits or so we are passed
it is a legal issue now it is a
political issue in like I see what
you're saying well see 16 I think Jordan
Peterson just really really
misrepresented that bill I read the bill
I read all the legal language I did not
see what he was saying in any at the
language of that bill and you know I
understand the be sort of what's the
snowball effect right so a key of this
morning where you know where someone you
oh well now we've open the door to this
and one next and people said that about
same-sex marriage - like oh you can
marry a man now I'm gonna bury your dog
or whatever yeah well I think that's a
right on I think it's a valid argument
just saying it's not an what do we go
now with MIT what about the males
dominating young girls sports now in
high school transgenders whether it's
wrestling or track you know what about
people who've been jailed in Canada for
using for firk engaging in what they
consider hate speech we've had them on
the show from people who run
bed-and-breakfast yeah in Canada for
hate speech what what was what was the
hate speech yeah that's a problem either
this or doesn't one of them mic war was
actually put for a Human Rights Tribunal
and I find and now it's being on appeal
so he's the one who's been on the show
most recently he made a joke about a kid
with a disability who was on make-a-wish
and was on a effectively the the
Canadian version of American Idol and he
made a joke that was deemed offensive
and was put before a Human Rights
Tribunal and accused of hate speech
Stephen Voss Saul was a pastor who spoke
counts that I'll never married two men
this is the religious view of marriage
that man was fined and I believe served
jail it happens all the time yes okay
well if that is indeed what happened and
that's what the bill and that's what the
bill I'm bowling I check myself but that
is indeed what happened that is messed
up and I don't I don't agree that you
know I support freedom of speech people
should be able to say whatever they want
including hate speech which is you know
I am anti hate speech but I think that
there's a tricky problem with trying to
restrict people's speech in any way and
the subjective lines around what is
considered hateful the only line that I
draw really is when you're inciting
violence sure I don't that that is
protected speech so you know no it's not
we agree philosophically but yeah I mean
i if this became a huge problem in the
United States I might have more sympathy
for that argument but you know as it
stands right now nobody's being sued for
using the prop the wrong pronouns or
whatever whoo landlords in New York to
start with can you give me some names
cuz like I haven't heard of that I just
gave you two and if I keep giving your
names in fact you say I don't believe
you you're doing the Naomi Wolf or they
said let's not check you afterwards so
this is in New York yeah
landlords in New York we've written
about it on the site extensively you
have plenty of professors who've gotten
in trouble obviously for for improper
language I mean I can't give you every
single single name but I've just given
you a handful so you're saying what's
the law it's the law yes the law as far
as I know okay it's that not misgender I
have bathrooms for what is it bathrooms
for like a lot of genders right like 20
or 30 or something at your place of
business
yeah done all landlords and misgendering
so there are laws now about misgendering
and the reason we come back to the
points why it's important I think maybe
the fundamental issue here maybe you and
I can find where we agree is where does
sex in your opinion and and gender begin
and how do we recognize that because
it's one thing to say I don't care what
someone says they want to put on a dress
and go in and call themselves Nancy fine
couldn't I think both of us agreed
couldn't care less
but where does sex stop and gender begin
and how do we define that legally as to
protect you know the rights of everybody
else who may not have agree with us and
may express that through speech well I
don't think there should be you know
punishments for misgendering
unless it's being used in a way that is
deliberately meant to harass or abuse
someone you know an accident a little
misgendering someone or even if you just
like can't get it right I don't think
that is a compelling case for criminal
activity but in general like if you're
if it's part of a pattern of harassment
and abuse toward someone then that's a
different context in a different story
you know and I think that in general
people should just try to respect
each other and just don't be an you know
just try to be kind to other people and
even if you don't understand why they
have pronouns that are different or why
they feel this way just try to
understand and be nice to other people
you know and and if it gets nasty like
let's come back to our shared where we
see things eye-to-eye as human beings I
I agree with being nice absolutely I
think it's important for gonna
restructure society how we view sex and
genders as you put it lit
differentiating between the two I think
it's important that we don't completely
restructure it and then say by the way
if you weren't along for the ride
you're in if we're gonna start finding
businesses if we're going to punish you
both for speech I think the onus is on
people to say gender is separate from
biology and this is why you have to go
along with it otherwise you know we put
you in jail or find you and I haven't
heard a compelling argument for that I
think that's how polish yeah well I
don't like I said I don't think we
should put people in jail or fined them
for for those sorts of things either but
I just I depends on what laws you know
it's hard to make general statements but
you know one of the ones that I one of
the debates that I find really
interesting is about you know sex and
sports like you mentioned before you
know we're trans women are playing
alongside sis women people who were born
biologically male before transitioning
and you know the way that that affects
your physicality we know this is just
you know basic biological fox that males
are on average larger and males are on
average have more muscle whereas females
have more fat and you know have
different reproductive capacities so you
know those are the situations where I'm
like this is really rough because I
don't think that we should I don't think
that we should tell people who are what
to be but I also think that would there
are some biological realities with sex
and those posts and difficult questions
and I think people need to be honest
with
selves and with others about what's fair
and what's not otherwise we're gonna get
into a situation that disadvantages
females who are smaller you know yeah
who have different athletic skills and
different abilities yeah cuz our bodies
are a little bit different
I agree with you I think a challenge
comes in there that a lot of people
consider as you've experienced now
consider that hate speech consider what
you just said at blush and everyone is
rushing with a legislative baton so
that's where it's important to determine
where you are if you draw the line at
sports some other people draw the lines
at words like the New York law like
we're talking about or in Canada which
is so far gone you know free speech
doesn't exist in any other country
outside of the United States so and
that's a roading here so everyone has a
line and I guess I guess my question is
how is society do we define that line
seems like to you it's things that are
physical sports but I yeah because the
the real tangible physical reality is
sex yeah you know you have a penis I
have a vagina your body is different
than my body right so that's just a
physical reality now those realities can
be shifted a little bit with various
medical interventions and I think that's
what makes it difficult because you know
somebody who is competing a trans woman
who is competing again alongside sis
women it's hard to say like to what
extent a trans woman's body is just like
a sis woman's body with medical
interventions and to what extent we see
these differences just naturally amongst
cisgender women anyway right like women
are different sizes as well it's not a
line of like yes I'm saying but they're
that these are like nuanced and
difficult issues if you want to be
really logically consistent about it
right and you want to say like well this
is the cutoff for size well what about
when you have a female you know a woman
who is born really big and you know you
see a lot of athletes who are just like
kind of anatomical and not anomalies
yeah basketball players and stuff like
they're huge they're not the average
this is where yeah I think this is where
generalizations are important and and
necessary and I think he said it's
nuanced but I don't hear a lot of
solutions this is coming from any and
not yourself these are very difficult
issues and I think some agenda that I'm
really not know I know I know you're not
I'm saying I do think there's only one
solution just like when I talk I've
talked about abortion whether to people
there's only one consistent line like I
said to draw logically and that sex is
biological and that's how we draw the
line sociologically the idea that gender
and sex are very different is a very new
idea right I mean it starts with you go
back to Simone de Beauvoir though in the
40s and then you have janmani and then
really this idea that it was non-binary
only started in the 80s and 90s with
Judith Butler even people talking about
transitioning I know you've talked about
this
still it was identifying with your
female so it's a very new idea and we're
restructuring everything on something
that's just not it's it's not defined in
science it's modern gender theory so
it's reductive the solution is reductive
you're right it's reductive no I hear
you I think I think that's a legitimate
it's a legitimate critique I just the
problem that I come up against I think I
like agree with you it may be more ways
than you realize just that my concern is
it's also important to me to make sure
that the world is equally accessible to
everybody you know regardless of who
they are whether they experience
dysphoria or not like it's important
that that everybody feel like they have
the same opportunities to be able to
pursue and you know the door is open to
anyone and it shouldn't be closed just
because you're trans you know so with
the sports stuff what do you do it how
do you solve that problem in a way that
doesn't close the door to people who
have a right to play sports and have a
right to compete and be athletes and
live their best lives you know that's
where I get kind of tripped up is how to
accommodate everybody at once you can
and actually I would disagree with your
statement oh degree
everything except for one thing you said
it's important that everyone has the
same accessibility and I agree but then
you said something which which struck me
they feel as though they have equal
opportunities I disagree they just need
to be ensured equal opportunities and
that solutions reductive I don't care
how they feel and we're talking about
the gender issue in sports it doesn't
matter how you feel you do have the same
opportunity that's a great example you
have the opportunity to compete as a man
which is how you were born you're the
same opportunity as every other person
who was born a man but I feel like woman
well it doesn't matter you compete as a
man equal opportunity there it's
reductive it is simplistic but it's it
wasn't we've created a problem now and
now people are gonna figure out how to
solve it there isn't a problem if you go
by biology well yeah I hear you I hear
you I I do get that's just like this
simple point-blank solution but I'm not
satisfied with this idea that people who
are women should have to compete
alongside men just because they were
born male you know like I think when you
understand and I don't know how much
exposure you have to real-life trans
people right oh okay so cool
so you probably are familiar with how
she just doing simple can be and I think
if there is a way to make people's lives
easier and to help them live the lives
that they want to live then we should do
it but I hear you in the sense that when
it comes to like athletics or physical
stuff really athletics is about your
body yeah about your sex so but some
people you know they fully they
transition and you know they're they're
hormonal makeup does change you know
particularly actually from female to
male because it is easier to trim it is
easier to add testosterone than to take
it away yeah from the body so let's say
you know or to certainly I would say to
I hate to but we actually Brian Shaw on
the show his world Strongest Man so to
certainly be talk we talked about
hormones a lot on the show it's a lot
easier to certainly change the
than to eliminate the effects of an
already testosterone Laden body and
can't undo the bone density I mean you
can you can do cancer by injecting
estrogen into a man but you can't undo
him becoming a man and that's why right
now you know we've hit the point with
puberty blockers and children and that's
another question which I'm against but
yeah yeah that would agree with your
statement there yeah so it's tricky I
mean I don't I don't know my mind is
open to solutions that make everybody
happy
but I don't feel like I've heard those
solutions and they don't exist maybe
you're right maybe we need to like have
more emphasis on sex or maybe you know
something that someone had told me that
I thought was an interesting idea is
going based on your weight class or on
your body composition so that people are
being matched based on people that are
like this the same size as them it
doesn't matter we already have that with
wrestling and that guy just beat the
[ __ ] out of a bunch of women in Texas
high school wrestling needs so you have
weight classes but a male weight champ
there's never ever been in any physical
come as a male champion versus a female
champion it seem like it's it's not
close and it's not fair to women that's
my point it's not fair to women well
that's you know I don't want biological
female people whether they are women are
meant to be October yeah well I I
appreciate your candor I think I don't
think there are solutions that please
everybody and I think the only
consistent line is uh is it is gender
and sex nor I until recently have long
been considered the same thing and these
are complications now or nuances that
are created in a way that can hurt
people
that's the shirt very physically as
we're talking about but this kind of
victim culture creates unintended
real-life victims this happens all the
time and there's no solution to please
everybody um so I think we both err on a
sudden many issues of freedom of speech
and of expression and and not infringing
on other people's rights I think you
should I think you're in the right place
and most of it just disagree with you
and some of the issues so your YouTube
channel we do have to get going I know
you're busy and I am as well is Laci
green TV that's Lacey see I again for
people listening and then go green 18
for as long as Twitter allows you to be
on there
yeah I don't really I'm really been
using social media much but yeah that's
that is where I'm at
and I have a book coming out in
September that goes into much more
detail about these matters I would love
to I would love to read it and I'd love
to have you back on to talk about it and
you also the patreon by the way I do I
do
yes where is where is that people to go
we'll bring it up in the lower third
here uh it's just Laci green I think
okay yeah thanks for the plug
absolutely Laci green and she might have
a bonus pretty soon she'll be in a tub
eating Cheerios yeah get your money's
worth I won't hold you to it but I will
picture it Laci green thank you very
much appreciate it and I do have to have
you back and I hope your books a success
thank you for taking the time subscribe
watch one of these other videos or hit
the notification Bell well you should
hit that if you subscribe anyways
because subscriptions don't mean
anything on YouTube anymore now you have
to get notifications and it shows up in
your inbox so I don't know why you
subscribed in the first place but that's
we have to do also we're not making
money off these videos anymore
because YouTube decided why they just
said we're not going to and when we said
why they didn't tell us why exactly
imagine if you showed up to your job to
do your work and then they said hey by
the way we're not gonna pay you said why
they said piss off